now I'm going to go ahead and take a
look at the code for defining an entity
let's imagine that you want to store
entities of kind recipe maybe you like
chocolate cake especially chocolate cake
covered in strawberries and sprinkles or
maybe you prefer pavlova this one looks
really good with Kiwis and strawberries
but whatever kind of cake you like your
recipe needs some properties obviously
it has to have a name a list of
ingredients some instructions
perhaps indicate the number of servings
and you can say whether it's vegetarian
not this might not be quite important
for cakes but could be really important
for like say lasagna if you use the
native App Engine datastore low level
Java API you need to create entities
with instances of the entity class
however the entity class is final so you
can't subclass it and you can't add
fields to it fortunately for us as an
open source library called objectify
objectify makes it easier to work with
entities by allowing you to define
classes that represent entities of a
particular kind then you simply add
fields to the class for each property
that you want your entities to have so
here's the code for the recipe entity
class notice the imports these packages
provide the objectify functionality for
defining entities
okay next notice is an entity annotation
this annotation indicates that this
class represents an entity the class
name is the kind of the entity so here
we're defining entities of kind recipe
this entity class has the properties
recipe ID name vegetarian servings and
so on when you use objectify every
entity class must have one and only one
property marked with the @ ID annotation
this is the entity's ID and it's used to
help uniquely identify the entity you
see that the rest of this class is just
a regular ol Java class it could have
more constructors and methods if you
wanted